What to do for a seven-year-old recently clinically diagnosed with alopecia
Either no symptoms besides
minimal hair loss
So alopecia again
Other autoimmune issue
Go to really should you should pay the 50 bucks to do my chronic disease an autoimmune course
because you
You have to know so when you're treating an autoimmune disease
I mentioned multiple times today you don't want to be stimulating in your response
But then you also
Have to look for hidden things. So okay, well, I'm not taking any immune stimulators. So I'm going to be fine
Well are there other ways that you're stimulating an immune response? Well, I don't know how okay
If you have anybody's to foods every time you eat that food
You're stimulating an immune response. So let's have antibodies to gluten. Okay, that's a big one
So no, I'm all completely good looking free and dairy free. I mean you're really good diet. Okay
Well still really good to do like a Syrex a right hand
Because you'll find out. Oh my gosh, I did I have antibodies to almonds
I drink almond milk every day because I'm very free
Okay, every time you drink that almond milk, you're stimulating an immune response destroyed self tissue possibly creating more
antibodies to other
self tissue creating a secondary tertiary, you know, and so on
Diagnosis of different autoimmune disorders. So you have to find the triggers. I cannot overemphasize that you have to find your triggers
How do you find your triggers? Well, I don't have money for testing
Then you're gonna have to you're gonna have to do some digging and put your Sherlock Holmes hammer
The best way to find triggers is to do appropriate testing of different antibodies different food anybody
So you can have triggers that are food source. You can have triggers that are environmental source. Hey, if I have
allergies that I have a hyper histamine reaction when I go outside of the spring
That's stimulating a TH1 response
And that's gonna make my autoimmune disease worse
So you you got to figure out those triggers of trying to calm those things down as best as possible
Well, this is very complicated. I know it's very complicated. It is very complicated
I know because people are looking for a doctor that just says here all you need to do is take this magic supplement
And you're gonna be all better
But I'll tell you most people have been to 40 doctors that have done these magic supplements
Maybe thousand dollars for the supplements and they didn't work and they got now a cupboard for them thousand dollars supplements and they don't work
Because it's a little more complex. So
You take that course. I think that will help you understand